en véritable voyage dans le temps depuis
le 2 décembre la maison de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux organise une
exposition gratuite sur les jouets
anciens pour les petits et les grands
plus de deux mille cinq cents objets
sont exposés dans cette caverne d'ali
baba pour collectionneurs vous retrouvez
tous les jouets de 10 de 1880 à 1980 à
peu près c'est la nostalgie je le vois
dans le regard des adultes plus que
presque que que les enfants encore jia
les adultes qui ont des yeux comme des
billes en retrouvant le télécran ou en
retrouvant le casimir ça ça fait plaisir
vraiment c'est une expo où les gens
arrivent avec le sourire à la porte
parmi les 200 m² de l'exposition les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir une maquette
légaux de cent mille pièces ou encore
des jouets rares comme ce jeu de pêche à
la ligne datant de 1890 le jeu de la
pêche à la ligne consistait premièrement
à faire entendre la sonorité aux enfants
et deuxièmement aller pêcher des objets
avec un aimant le lutz et de pêcher
l'objet avant que l'objet ne passent sur
le pont
donc l'objet donc l'enfant empêcher un
objet il le prenait regardait et là ils
avaient péché par exemple effectivement
une chaussure
en bois en fer blanc en plastique ou en
métal les jouets permettent également
aux visiteurs d'observer une part de
l'histoire selon les organisateurs
j'étais assez frappé par la fille qui
avait le fer à repasser la machine à
laver la dînette et le garçon qui jouait
plutôt aux gendarmes et aux voleurs
aux petites voitures et puis garçon qui
avait un métier la fille un peu moins je
trouve voilà ce fait en préparant sa
c'est ça qui m'a frappé l'exposition se
déroule du mardi au dimanche jusqu'au 20
décembre une excuse pour retomber
définitivement en enfance al'approche
des fêtes de noël